B Project, who made our second Japan Dome live a success,
are sorry for being late, A&
R. [
Music]
Tsubasa-chan, you look a little tired. Once you've calmed
down, let's have a coffee
date with me. Don't push yourself too hard, Master.  You're
right. Don't get so reckless that you collapse.
Nesu-san, if there's anything you can do to help us, feel
free to let us know. When you're tired,
watch episode 33 of Mami. No, to recover your physical strength, you'll need
protein for the time being.  If you don't have time to eat breakfast, I
recommend bananas.Everyone is on my
side.I'm really short on wings.I'd like to
drink tea with you again.We're
working with great enthusiasm, too, so we'll be
waiting to see you at the site.  We are
always one.
[Music] I
also know more than ever how to open up new fields and discover new artists.
Lucky Ursultra. Hello, I'm Vita. Maybe I'm
nervous about this or that. Let's do it.
My favorite thing to do is to sing and dance and make people smile, so that's why I play
games.